oscar-winning filmmaker author and
mountain climber Jimmy Chen is out with
a new documentary series called edge of
the unknown it looks at near-death
experience of the world's best adventure
athletes and how they come back from
that edge Lily Luciano recently met up
with chin at Kelly Slater's surf Ranch
in California for a lesson on the
importance of embracing failure in order
to find success
foreign
for almost two decades Jimmy chin has
made it his life's work to dangle
perilously close to the edge now for his
latest project he's going one step
further to be an elite Adventure athlete
you have to push past the fear to
achieve a Transcendent experience
sometimes the only way to find the edge
is to go over it
his new series edge of the unknown
brings together some of the world's
Elite extreme athletes and explores the
moments they come face to face with
death in my first couple trips I was
really scared and scared not just on a I
might get hurt but like there was a
death component what does it take to
excel at something where you're really
putting your life on the line one thing
that you have to be willing to do is you
need to be willing to fail because it's
always about this process of failure
learning from the failure and moving
forward
from getting buried in an avalanche
stalked by a polar bear to almost
drowning after going over a 60-foot
waterfall these stories are about how
they react reset and keep going we spent
days rigging on the root chin says he's
looking to do more than take viewers on
an extreme adventure for him it's a
lesson in turning failure into success
were you comfortable with failure I
think that was one of my biggest hurdles
is that I was brought up
to perform perfectly whether that was
playing the violin or swimming
competitively but in that process I also
did learn that you had to try things
multiple times until you got it right
Chen began scaling mountains as a
teenager he was one of the first
Americans to successfully ski from the
summit of Mount Everest and made history
reaching India's meru Peak it's hard to
not imagine your friend falling through
the frame to his death in 2019 chin
reached the Pinnacle of filmmaking
earning an Oscar for free solo there's
this idea that this athlete is just
chasing the adrenaline of exploring the
easiest way to die and it's quite the
opposite it's that Transcendent
experience where you are in a state of
flow where everything else Falls away
and you're in a space of non-thought and
the world slows down and it's just this
incredible experience anybody watching
an elite athlete who faces death in that
way thinks well that's a death wish but
on the contrary the people doing that
seem to me like the ones who are living
the most fully I couldn't have put it
better that is
a big part of what I think is a
misperception around what these athletes
do and who they are and why they do it
you know it is to live
and to live fully here we go and the
Explorer he is that also means branching
out
his latest passion surfing it's nice to
have something like this where there's
no pressure because I'm I'm not a
professional Surfer
it's why he keeps coming back to Kelly
Slater's surf Ranch and it's like a
perfect wave
and there's like a really great
opportunity of a progression here he
says it's good for
there and try I'm originally from Puerto
Rico I should not tell you that so you
don't expect that I'm in a surf good
[Music]
at the surf Ranch I came face to face
with failure once twice and eventually
it's all part of Chin's philosophy in
life and the water he says just commit
and figure it out you'll figure it out
for CBS mornings milia Luciano leave me
in California
[Music]
wow okay Lilia
Luciano and she's moved to New York
though not a lot of Great Waves all
right